just in the last day the last two days
we have gotten three new candidates for
the Republican nomination for president
first new candidate up for the
Republican Presidential nomination
came out just moments before I started
the show today
former South Carolina governor former
ambassador to the UN Nikki Haley
Republicans have lost a popular vote in
seven out of the last eight presidential
elections that has to change Joe Biden's
record is abysmal but that shouldn't
come as a surprise the Washington
establishment has failed us over and
over and over again
it's time for a new generation of
leadership
to ReDiscover fiscal responsibility
secure our border and strengthen our
country our pride and our purpose
[Music]
some people look at America and see
vulnerability
the Socialists left sees an opportunity
to rewrite history
China and Russia are on the March they
all think we can be bullied kicked
around
should know this about me I don't put up
with bullies and when you kick back it
hurts them more if you're wearing heels
I'm Nikki Haley and I'm running for
president
[Music]
all right we got Nikki in the race we
knew that she was going to run even
though Nikki has a little bit of a
problem in that she previously had said
that if Trump runs for president she
would not run nobody really believed
that politicians say that all the time
it seemed pretty clear that she was she
was going to run
I know there are going to be a lot of
conservatives who say not a chance I I
think Nikki Haley's too moderate I'm not
going to vote for her
the thing to remember though is
the conservatives are not the only part
of the Republican Party
there are a lot of moderates in the
Republican party there are a lot of
right-leaning kinds of people and there
is a push in general elections for more
moderate candidates
most republican nominees
in the last
70 years
have been pretty moderate
Trump not quite so much
but Romney pretty moderate McCain pretty
moderate George W bush pretty moderate
Bob Dole pretty moderate George H.W bush
pretty moderate Ronald Reagan more
conservative he was a little bit of an
exception to that
Jerry Ford pretty moderate Richard Nixon
pretty a little more conservative but
pretty moderate
Barry Goldwater not so moderate though
it's on social issues actually somewhat
moderate but
Dwight Eisenhower
the the centrists are the rule when it
comes to the nomination and so I think
that's probably what Nikki Haley is
seeing here Nikki Haley is running it
would appear just from this ad a a
relatively conventional campaign and I
suspect that's a strategy I suspect the
strategy is we've had a couple of very
unconventional election Cycles people
want to return to normalcy that's why
they voted for Joe Biden if they voted
for Joe Biden in 2020 and so we're going
to give them a kind of uh strong on
National Defense cut the taxes bring
everybody together sort of platform
conventional kind of campaign ad present
yourself in a way that is warm and
inviting but you know you can you can
still claim some conservative Bona fides
I'm I'm not saying it's going to work
but there is a lane for Nikki Haley if
people believe that there is not a lane
for Nikki Haley I think you were totally
kidding yourself
uh and I I happen to like Nikki Haley
personally very much I don't I don't
know how the field is going to shake out
because the fact that she is entering
into this race is just one more data
point to show you
everybody's going to enter I think I am
probably going to be the last
even somewhat public conservative and
Republican who is not running in 2024
and really that's only because I'm
constitutionally ineligible right now
because I'm too young but if I if
everyone is going to get in okay uh Tim
Scott announced that he is going to get
into the race or at least it's being
heavily floated by his team this would
be another example
of someone saying I'm not going to run
and then running Tim Scott when his
Memoir came out I think it was last
summer the the publisher accidentally
leaked that he was preparing for a
presidential run
and so that news leaked and Tim Scott
said no I'm absolutely not it's not
happening nobody believed that we all
knew that he was preparing a run and and
that has just been leaking to the Press
again and then a third person in the
last 24 hours has has floated that he's
going to run this would be uh a buddy of
mine from college actually vivec
ramaswamy the bank ramaswamy is a a
completely unconventional candidate uh
Vivek ramaswami is a entrepreneur he's
done very very well for himself he's an
extremely intelligent guy and he would
be running as a businessman as a guy who
thinks a little bit outside of the box
as a guy who kind of in the Andrew Yang
slash Donald Trump kind of way I think
and that he hasn't held public office
before but
but do not underestimate this guy
this guy is very very intelligent very
talented guy very motivated he
some people are going to write him off
as a long shot candidate I think that
would be a crazy thing to do especially
in this field I
personally think that it's it's wise for
all of these people to get in and
especially for Vivek to get in
if Donald Trump had cleared the field
then he would be the nominee
if the race were Trump versus DeSantis
it would be a real shootout maybe
DeSantis would even have an advantage at
least in the polling if you look at it
right now
but the fact that neither Trump nor
DeSantis could scare everybody else off
means that
it's going to be a 20-person field
that's just what it means
and in a gigantic field Trump actually
has the advantage
if it were just Trump that's good for
Trump if it were Trump versus DeSantis
that's bad for Trump because it's a head
to head if it were Trump versus DeSantis
versus Haley versus ramaswamy versus Tim
Scott versus I don't know Mike Pompeo
versus Mike Pence versus maybe Ted Cruz
Maybe Who
all of a sudden Trump has the advantage
again and that's what you saw in 2016.
where Trump was polling 30 35 but he
just had a plurality he had he had more
than the other people did my favorite
thing about this field people are always
going to be trying to ask well
did you or who are you endorsing you
know I I'm trying to make a point as
best I can not to endorse too much in
primaries
but my favorite thing about this field
is that
right now of the current and prospective
candidates
I think most of them have endorsed my
books that's the main thing that matters
to me right now about the field
Nikki Mike Pompeo Senator Cruz
I think there was a there's one more
endorsed uh speechless controlling words
controlling Minds which is available now
number one National bestseller thank you
very much uh
president Trump endorsed my first book
reasons to vote for Democrats a
comprehensive guide also available right
now I think I'm missing one or two uh in
any case though this is really really
important this is the main thing forget
about the economy forget about
immigration forget about foreign policy
the main thing is right now we have a
field that is shaping up where uh a huge
number of them have a really really
great taste in books so I'm very very
excited for the 2024 race the rest of
the show continues now the member block
is on you don't want to miss it use code
Knowles kwels at checkout for two months
free on all annual plans dailywire.com
Knowles we will see you in the member
block
[Music]
foreign